Sup guys. I'm in hawaii. You've been asking for a vlog so here's a vlog now
I don't normally do vlogs, but we're going to try it out and if you don't like it
Give me a thumbs down on this video if you do like it
Give me a thumbs up on this video if we get a hundred thousand thumbs ups maybe I'll make another vlog
But here's what we're doing today. My wife is over here on the hammock hanging out [checking] social media or something and
In my hand. And my little boy is over here blowing bubbles right you got to love how there's like palm trees everywhere
[we've] got coconut start over here coconut tree, and if we turn [right] we've got a little banana tree right there as well, [so]
[we've] been going to the beach [pretty] much every day today
We're going to the dole plantation, and I've got my meet up tonight at the sand Island the ala
Moana Beach Park area at 4:30 to 5:30. I don't really expect anybody's going to show up
It's kind of a small island short notice
But I thought it would be terrible if I miss the opportunity to do a meet-up in Hawaii while we're here
We have been here for two [weeks]. [I've] filmed and worked on videos every single day since we've been here
It's supposed to be a vacation but for me. It's [just] kind of a relocation vacation
It's been a ton of fun though, and you can't beat the scenery
This is our backyard [the] place that we're staying we've got palm trees banana trees coconut trees
Looking down you see random coconuts everywhere
We've busted open a lot of coconuts, and had a lot of coconut milk and juice and we're loving it cool Little trick
I figured out was you could take the husk out of the inside of coconut shells like this and turn it into rope
So I've got a tutorial coming on how to do that how to make rope [out] of coconut husk
[I] also visited the polynesian cultural center [and] learned some cool tricks on making one of those Hawaii
Headbands out of palm leaves and cool little fish toys. So we got some tutorials coming on as well
We take you inside the house and give you a little house tour
So this is our little beach house is where we're staying my friend mark is with us. That's his bed right there
We didn't have enough room for him
He's over here right now working on some of the audio that we just record on the beach
We're doing a sponsored video for lifevantage. So we're putting that together recording with this equipment here
This is a sony A6300 and we only have two bedrooms
So that's where Janae
And I sleep and this is where the kids are [sleeping] right now looks like we got reefs in they're working on Minecraft right now
House is pretty cool. It's got little paintings all over the walls nice Little Hawaiian decorations
It's not a bad little place to hang out. It's costing us [about] [$3,000] to be here for three weeks
[the] shower is Terribly small, but at least it works. I
Just got the stealth shelf loaded up. I'm going to be giving this thing away today down on the sand Island in the ala
Moana Beach Park area it is our first factory prototype, and I just don't have enough room in my luggage to take it home
So I thought it made more sense to give it away [160] dollar value plus free shipping
But somebody who comes out to see me today is going to get that it's Gonna be fun
Oh and Here's some of my headbands that I've made these are made out of palm leaves and once you learn the technique
It's just a simple weave but very cool
And I love wearing these things makes me feel like an island boy all right off to the dole plantation. We're here dole plantation
You guys gotta see these trees these are crazy trees are like multicolored like all the different layers of bark that peel off green Maroon
Orange
very very pretty
so we had huge
Construction driving out here it took about 40 minutes longer than it should have that means we've only got an hour here at the [dole]
Plantation to ride a train go see the fish get a dole whip and head over to Magic Island so we can do the meet
Up tonight
is that
Got the whole crew loaded up, and we were headed down to Magic Island for the main group
So some of you know many of you do not I used to live [in] Hawaii
I used to work out here flying the mail for one of the local [airlines] from Island Island [and] I wrote a moped and this
Is the Nimitz Highway that I would ride in Honolulu all the time?
I worked the night shift which means I had the days free and I would go exploring during the days
So it worked as a tour bus driver for Roberts Hawaii. How crazy. Is that okay?
So update we are in rush-hour traffic on Nimitz Highway however. We're only ten minutes away from Magic Island
[it's] 405 that means we're gonna get there at 4:15. That's 15 minutes early for the [meet and] great things are looking good so far
*unintelligible*
All right, lets go fly a drone
All right, I think it's time to do the drawing on the stealth shelf
*unintelligible*
Like whoo look at I know I like what are you looking at? Oh your self? Yes, you're so handsome
Yeah, you see that is my queen of Random anyway
It's like a quarter to seven right now where our one-hour session turned into like two almost two and a half hours
Yeah, there were there were probably over a hundred people that showed up tonight. That was so awesome so cool
honestly, I thought we're gonna choke to the park and just have lunch and then go home and I wish we had some lunch because
Our children are starving people of oahu are awesome. Yeah, we love you guys in a great time well, what an incredible day?
We just made it home. We did stop at Costco and got some pizzas
I had the whole family [it] was awesome stuff, and my phone's got 1% battery left
So it's going to shut off any second now, so [I] just wanted to say thanks for the day mahalo
I'll see you the next video, right?